こんにちははじめしゃちょーです今日は
はじめしゃちょーの人生に
欠かせない10のアイテム
で皆さん人生において俺は私はこれだけは
絶対持ってないといけないこれだけは絶対
私の俺の人生に欠かせないわっていう
アイテムありませんか多分ね10個とは
言わなくても絶対12個はあると思うん
ですよで今日はYouTuberのはじめ
しゃちょーはじめしゃちょーが人生におい
て欠かせないアイテム10個ちょっと考え
ました考えましたっていうかナックちゃ
いけないから考えなくていいんですこれを
構成するアイテム10個もう欠かせない
アイテムが10個はあったのでそれを
ちょっと紹介していきたいと思いますさあ
僕と言い始めさという人間自分のものの話
ってそんなしないから結構気になってる人
いるかわかんないですけどもはじめしゃ
ちょーってこの10個のもので生きてるん
だっていうのをちょっとぜひ皆さんに紹介
できたらいいなと思っておりますよかっ
たら是非見てってくださいでは行こう
[音楽]
まずはもう
スマホですスマートフォンで
iPhone14ProMax最新型の
iPhoneの一番大きいやつですねまあ
スマホは欠かせないでしょみんな生活
必需品を連絡を取りますし動画も撮ります
しこうやってもうこれね電話というより
もうねちっちゃいパソコンよ動画も撮れる
電話もできる連絡も取れるゲームも遊べる
で俺手がねめっちゃ大きいんだよバスケ
やってたか知んないけど手がめっちゃ
大きいからスマートフォンiPhoneも
一番大きいプロマックスの容量マックスお
仕事上動画もたくさん撮ったりするので
最新型の一番大きいサイズの一番大きい
容量も全てを限界までマックスにした
iPhoneこれは僕欠かせないです1日
8回なくします断りのポイントとしては
そうね色がねパープル紫の本体なのと
iPhoneケースもねそんなね
特徴的ではないクリアのやつですねなんか
チャラチャラした見た目ですけども実は
シンプルなのが好きでちょっと今日の
欠かせない10のアイテムばっと並べてみ
たら多分俺がどんな人間かわかると思い
ます結構ね
シンプルが好きなんですよ何の変哲もない
iPhoneケースに最大容量最大サイズ
最新型のiPhoneですこれは多分知ら
ない人が多いだろうなあ
香水これディオールのソバージュという
構成なんですけどもこれプレゼントで
もらったやつでもう匂いがめっちゃいいん
ですよ
まずモテるこれはねモテる匂いですよ
香水つけるキャラじゃないじゃん
香水つけるキャラじゃないんですけども
自分からこの匂いしたら嬉しいなっていう
匂いを再現できているというかDiorの
ね多分人気の構成なんですけど見た目も超
かっこいいし
持ち運びやすいし男子も女子も好きな匂
いっていうのかな爽やか系の香りがします
でもね香水って本当にねなんかあれよつく
と同じようなもんよ服を身にまとうように
匂いも身にまとうものなんです誰かにどう
思われたいというより自分の気持ちが
高まるからねちょっとこれは持ってたいか
な結構欠かせないなっていうアイテムです
次これはもう知ってる人いるんじゃないか
なエルメスの
クロコダイルのワニの皮の
財布です動画でね
170万円ぐらいしたかな100万円が
財布を買いに行こうという企画しに行っ
たらエルメスさんに100万円の財布が
ないぞと170万しかないよっていうこと
で自腹で払わせてもらって買った
財布です
やっぱりねいいですちょっとそろそろお
手入れしてあげたいなだいぶツヤツヤ感が
なくなったんですけども
めっちゃ丈夫なのよさすが革財布といった
ところかまあ本当に無くさなくなったね
この財布にしてあなくした2回ほどなくし
ましたちなみに俺エルメスのこの
170万円の財布の前の財布100円
ショップで買った財布だったんでかなり
爆発的になんかね財布の値段は上がったん
ですけど
思っちゃうけど逆にこういう財布に見合う
男になりたいなと思ってくださいこれは
事実に欠かせません近くで買っちゃった
財布なんですけどもちょっと一生ものの
財布だと思ってます
その変えようかなちょっと大きいのよ
かなり大きいからなくしにくい反面
めちゃめちゃ運びには不便というかコーチ
みたいにぶら下げてたいぐらいの
さすがエルメス品質はもう最高です俺は
ちょっと俺の人生には欠かせないかな
[音楽]
任天堂SWITCHの有機ELでござい
ますこれはもう
欠かせないよ普通のNintendo
SWITCHと違って有機ELっていう
新しいタイプのSWITCH画面が
めっちゃくちゃ大きいのよはじめしゃ
ちょーゲーマーなのでずっとゲームやって
て最近はもうポケモンかな最新作の
ポケモンずっとやったりスマブラももう
ずっとやってるねあと最近だとロック
マイクとかも出たかなもう本当に色んな
ゲーム楽しませてもらっててで持ち運びも
できるし誰かとこうやってコントローラー
分けてもできるこのまま持ち運んでるわけ
じゃないんですけど去年のポケモンの
ロンドンの世界大会のSWITCHケース
にこうやって入れてはじめしゃちょーって
いう人間の大きな要素としてゲームは絶対
欠かせないのでSWITCHはね結構
持ち歩いてますねマジで欠かせないあと
ワンポイント
可愛いポイントとして俺の
NintendoSWITCHの裏にです
ねにゃんのシールが1枚だけ貼ってあり
ますゲーム関係っていうか
[音楽]
ポケモンGOポケモンGOですよポケモン
GOはね俺はもう人生だと勝たせないね
まだポケモンGOやってるのっていう人
いると思うんですけどもあまりよポケモン
GO出た時はさ本当もうありとあらゆる人
がみんなこぞりもこぞってポケモンGOを
遊んでたと思うんですけどもあの一大
ブームを去った今も実は
めっちゃたくさんの人が長いちょっと遊ん
でてそれもすごいのがね年齢層関係ないん
ですよちっちゃい子供とか学生さんとか俺
とかあとお父さんお母さん世代おじい
ちゃんおばあちゃんも遊んでるんですよ
近所の公園でおじいちゃんがあのミュウ
ツーの最高ブレイカーじゃなくておばあ
ちゃんに話してるの見て俺このゲームマジ
ですごいなと思って年齢層を問わない
ゲームこれ最強だと思うんですよずっと
遊んでるね
旅行とか行くじゃん遠くとか行ったりそこ
限定のポケモンとかも出てくるからそう
いう楽しみ方もできるし
気にしないとこのキャラ出ませんみたいな
のもないから
焦らず
楽しく俺ひょっとしたらこれ一生遊ぶん
だろうなと思ってなんとなくポケモンGO
遊ばせていただきますアプリで申し訳ない
んですけどポケモンGOも俺の人生であっ
た
欠かせないアイテムの一つになってます
これはね結構動画で映ってるけど知らない
人多いんだろうなアクセサリーですそれも
この特定のアクセサリー
ルイヴィトンセットまずはこれだね
ネックレスですねはっきりと書いてあるん
ですけどもこれ
全部ダイヤモンドでできてるんですよこれ
ダイヤモンドでできてて
値段がね確か
110万ぐらいだったかな110万ぐらい
した気がしますねなんで買ったんだっけな
何かが原因で
辛いことがあった時に俺は
もっと自分を大事にしようみたいななんか
自分のためにお金とかも使おうみたいな
なんかそういう気持ちで買った覚えがあっ
てなんでだっけな
失恋になったかな自分のために100万円
以上のものをあんまり買ったことがない
からじゃあもう首元で俺はこの100万円
のネックレスを一生下げておこうという
めっちゃキラキラしてるしなんかつけてる
だけですごい俺は自分を大事にっていう
気持ちを忘れないために
伊藤さんで買わせていただいたネックレス
だった思い出がありますとりあえずずっと
つけてるこれは別になんかねそのお金持ち
キラキラアピールしたいわけじゃないんだ
けど的なものを身につけてると気持ちが
上がるし俺はそういう思い入れがあって
買ったからこれはもう欠かせないねこれ
なくしたら1週間は寝込みます
去年ねなんか俺すっげえ忙しくてめっちゃ
頑張ったのよ頑張った自分のご褒美に
はじめよく頑張った今年も去年に関しては
なんか結構ね悔しい思いとかもしたから
そんな自分を褒め称え
るってわけじゃないんですけども自分への
ご褒美に俺の好きな赤黒のブレスレットを
買いましたこれもルイヴィトンですねこれ
ヴィトンのボルトっていう
シリーズなんですけども
紐の部分でちょっとかわいらしいと思っ
たら
ギュってガツンとここに稲妻形になってる
のが超かっこよくて俺の好きで固めてあり
ますねもうライトニングみたいなイナズマ
も好きだし赤と黒っていう好きな色で
さりげないこういうちょっとしない稲妻が
マジでかっこいいんだよなそして最近よく
つけてるこの金色の指輪これねいつも俺が
すげえお世話になってる一緒に編集して
くれてるスタッフの後輩がいるんですけど
もその子が
誕生日プレゼントでくれたやつですねそう
いうお世話になってる人からのプレゼン
トって結構
ぐっとくるというか本当に嬉しくて指に
これは結構はめるようにしてますこれ結構
特定のアクセサリーをずっとつける傾向に
なってキンキンキンでゴールドセットこれ
はねとりあえずつけるねこのネックレスと
このブレスレットこのリングつけて初めて
はじめしゃちょー完成みたいな気持ちでは
あります
それくらいねなんかこう気持ちが入ると
いうか
欠かせないものになってますねかっこいい
続いてはこちらYouTuberと言っ
たらありきたりですけどもパソコンです
MacBookProのちっちゃいやつか
な14インチかな14インチの
MacBookProですちっちゃい
でしょめっちゃ持ち運び便利なのよ俺
やっぱ静岡と東京の動画多いからパソコン
も小さくしようと思って一回り小さい
MacBookにしましたがお値段
約100万円
+90万円
ぐらいだった気がしますこのサイズでその
値段ってことはクソパワフルなんですよ
マジでやばいでっかいデスクトップもある
んですけどもこのノートパソコンの方が
AppleM2MAXっていうチップが
なんかやばいらしくて
編集もサクサクサクサク最近はずっとこの
パソコンで編集してます
移動も楽だしもう
欠かせないねこれはここも俺のシンプル
好きが出てますね何にも貼らない1個前の
やつ貼ってたんですけどもやっぱ何もない
のが俺好きだなと思ってかと言って落とす
のも落として壊れるのも嫌だからクリア
ケースだけつけてシンプル
なこのサイズ持ち運び
便利だしこのサイズ14インチ持ち運びも
便利だし編集も超余裕でできるからもう俺
はこのサイズが一番いいかなと思ってます
これは欠かせないね俺にとって何よりも
大事なものだと思ってます次はこちら
リュックですあんまり
初めて社長リュックのイメージないと思う
んですけども最近よく背負ってますねパッ
と見黒を貴重なんですけどもちょっと
サファリっぽい明細からぽくなっててこれ
キングズっていうサマンサタバサさんの
なんかブランドなのかなこれね
確か世界に1個しかないです
わかんない作られてるかもしれないけど
そんなないのかなちょっとわかんないなで
も確か俺と思い出によると世界に1個しか
なかったと思う違ったらごめんこれに俺
サマンサタバサさんのコラボしてグッズ
作った時があったんですもその時になんか
こっそり俺用にねこのリュック作って
もらったのよはじめしゃちょーとサマンサ
タバタのコラボロボが入ってるっていう
唯一的なリュック使うわけにはいかんやろ
ということでもう最近ずっと使わせて
もらってますまあめっちゃ大きいのとここ
開けなくても俺ズボラだからここから物を
取り出せたりするのよ
MacBookがね
[音楽]
唯一無二っていうかマジで最高ですこれ
専用のリュックです
専用とか言われたら
社長
元気ですか
ヨギボーです
[音楽]
ヨギボーは3億円のおうちに引っ越した時
にお家が広すぎて寂しくてちょっとなんか
勢いで100万円分買って
Yogiboでなんかお家埋め尽くそうと
思ってたくさん買ったんですけども
100万円分ね
買ってよかったですこれ100万円分買っ
て正解でしたもうめっちゃ柔らかいのよ
寝ることもできるし
編集とかもこうやってできるのよこれはね
ちょっと
万能ですね100万円分買ってめっちゃ
たくさんあったんですけどほとんど友達と
か後輩とかいろんな人にあげまくって今
残り67個ぐらいしかも容疑もないんです
けどこれは人生に欠かせないですね
こういう座り方もできるのよはじめしゃ
ちょーの
癒しの部分ではかなりもう絶対必要だと
思ってます1個は絶対欲しいねこれはと
いうことで色々紹介してきたんですけれど
も最後のはじめしゃちょーの人生において
欠かせないアイテム
3億円のお家ですここ今いるここですもう
欠かせないね
隠せないというか俺もまだ把握しきれて
ないものというか無限の可能性があるのよ
今までもいろんな動画を撮らせてもらった
し今はまだ改良している部分とか改装して
いるところがあったりまだねこのお家の
可能性無限にあります俺こう家だと思って
ないのよ遊び場というか
史上最強のはじめしゃちょーの動画
撮るスタジオ最近だとサウナもできたし
もうねここから先が楽しみなはじめしゃ
ちょーで欠かせないものの
一つ思ってます家買ったからさ
賃貸とかだったらこんなこと言えないけど
自分の持ち物だから俺の大切なアイテムの
10個のうちの1つに入れさせてもらい
ました始めた3億円のおうちはいという
感じでしたはじめしゃちょーの人生におい
て欠かせない10のアイテムどうでしたか
見たことあるよっていうものとかも
たくさんあったけども
意外なものとか何でつけてるのかなとか
そういうのあんまり話したことなかったの
で話してみました皆さんはなんか欠かせ
ないアイテムありますかよかったら
コメント欄で教えてください以上
[音楽]